yesterday I did a video about young
Earth Creationism and I explained why in
my opinion based on what the text says
and based on what we know from science
we should not interpret de to mean a
24-hour period and I explained that that
even if we are if we are taking it
literally I think that in the context of
Genesis the literal interpretation of
day would not be 24 hours that would
actually be a non literal interpretation
because the literal interpretation of
day all has to do not with with with how
many hours but with the rotation of the
earth and there's absolutely no reason
to believe that in the first three first
three days of creation as its told that
you would have an earth that is rotating
on a 24-hour cycle anyway you can go to
iTunes or you can go back and watch that
video to hear my whole argument needless
to say everyone agreed with me there was
there was really no debate at all there
was no dissension and unanimous
consensus was formed everybody went home
went home happy just kidding of course
people told me I was a heretic and that
I would burn in hell well not everyone
some people told me that many people
though were very thoughtful and
respectful in their disagreements that
it was an interesting conversation now
during that conversation one thing that
I heard from atheist that I want to use
as the springboard for today one thing I
heard from atheists quite a bit is is
this they said well if you're saying
that it's scientifically impossible for
God to create the universe in six days
then why won't you accept that it's
scientifically impossible for a person
to be resurrected from the dead and
young earthers actually make kind of the
same argument but they frame it the
opposite way where they say well if you
if you think it's scientifically
possible for a person be raised from the
dead
why don't you think it's possible for
God to make the world in six days so I'd
like to talk about the resurrection and
whether or not science disproves it
whether or not it's rational to believe
in it but first before we get into that
just to clarify I do not believe and did
not say that it's impossible for God to
make the world in six days God can do
whatever he wants God is all-powerful
God could make the world in 6 seconds
God could make the world in any amount
of time that he chooses God that that's
what it means to be all-powerful
my position is not that he can't do it
in six days it's just that he didn't do
it in six days from my reading of the
text and looking at science I think that
he did not do it though it's not a it's
not a statement of what he can and can't
do it's a statement about what he
apparently did do just like if you
believe that God could God did make the
world in six days
you're not saying I don't think you're
saying they couldn't have or he core he
couldn't make it in six billion years or
ten or ten billion years or whatever
you're just saying that he didn't do it
that way so this is a discussion not of
what he can do but of what he did do I
think it's possible for God to make you
know babies in in in the sky and then
drop them down into our arms like he
could do that but he doesn't do that he
follows a process for making babies and
in learning about that process we are by
no means limiting God we are by no means
setting parameters for God he sets the
parameters we're just learning the
parameters and trying to understand them
so that we can understand more about
this wonderful world that he's given us
so since we're on the subject let's deal
with the atheist contention that science
disproves God and disproves the
resurrection let's ask ourselves whether
whether we must choose between science
or the central doctrines of the faith or
more perhaps more to the point is it
reasonable is it rational to believe in
the resurrection must we leave our
reason behind if we're going to venture
down that road and become Christians so
let's start here let's start with one
basic principle here science cannot
disprove God okay it cannot disprove the
supernatural by definition science is a
thing for the natural realm the claim of
a Christian or of any theist is that
there is also a supernatural realm which
science can't
anything about and I think intelligent
atheists atheists who are careful and
measured in their arguments they know
this to be the case they understand this
so if you listen to Dawkins or if you
you know if you read or go and watch a
YouTube video of Christopher Hitchens
you'll find that this this is the way
that they phrase it you know they'll say
something like well science doesn't need
God or science works without God
they don't say that science disproves
God because they know they can't say
that they know that that would be a
sloppy thing to say that they can't
possibly support now of course I
disagree with their contention that
science doesn't need God or works
without him but it's instructive that
they do phrase the contention that way
rather than saying that science offers
positive proof that God does not exist
that's more something that like a sloppy
kind of atheist in a youtube comment
section would say but smart ones know
better they're not going to say that
naturalism ok naturalism is the belief
that there is nothing but the natural
there's nothing but the physical world
what you see is what you get basically
that is a philosophical position it is
not a scientific position and if you go
into a study of Scripture with that
presupposition in mind then you're going
to of course rule out all of the
miraculous claims that you come across
immediately because it contradicts your
philosophy not because it contradicts
science now Christians and Jews believe
in a God who transcends the physical
world and is not subject to its rules so
you cannot disprove God by applying the
rules of the physical world to him he
sets those rules and in the fact the
fact that the rules are so orderly the
fact that you can do mathematics and you
can do physics and you can work out
equations and calculations and learn
about the world and it all makes so much
sense that is evidence for God not
against him you know there's that famous
Einstein quote where he said the most
incomprehensible thing about the world
is that it is comprehensible so he was
speaking of
the incredible order and discern ability
of the universe which is not what you
would expect if we're talking about a
random universe that was just that came
out of nothing and came out of chaos you
would not expect a universe that has
ordered itself like this a universe that
can be understood a universe that
follows certain firm laws in a random
and chaotic universe why should we be
able to know or understand anything much
less why should we even be here in the
first place as as as living beings and
especially as conscious beings how could
these random forces assemble themselves
in such an orderly way and then create
out of nothing out of the void
intelligent beings who can grasp these
concepts and talk about them and argue
about them how could that happen again
this is evidence for God not against him
the fact that you can do science at all
would seem to give credence to the idea
that the universe was constructed by an
intelligent designer who had a purpose
and a plan in mind so we can deduce I
think from the intelligibility of the
universe that there must be a God behind
it that's a deduction we can make now of
course we cannot perform some kind of
equation and then or or work out some
kind of like you know do some some kind
of calculus and then and then say aha
well there's God he's right there you
can't do that any more than you can
perform an equation and conjure up love
right God is transcendent non-physical
all-powerful not subject to the laws
that he makes
we cannot say therefore that anything is
scientifically impossible for God now we
can say that certain things are
logically impossible for God or for
anyone scientific impossibilities are
different from logical impossibility
God can create a universe out of nothing
that is not a scientific impossibility
for him he cannot create a round square
or a rectangular triangle because those
are logical and possibilities in that
they are nonsense and
God does not cannot engage in nonsense
nonsense as nonsense so it's like if you
were if you were to ask God the question
what's the color of the number seven
that's a question God can't answer
because it's an it is a depth by
definition an unanswerable nonsense
question so when confronted with claims
when we you know when we are confronted
with claims that God did this or that we
can analyze those claims on two levels
to try and figure out if the claims
might be true number one we can ask is
this claim consistent with the nature of
God number two we can ask is it
logically possible we can't ask is it
scientifically possible we can't ask is
it logically possible when someone says
that God instructed them to blow up a
school bus full of children we can say
definitively that that claim is false
because it is not consistent with God's
nature when someone says that 2+2 equals
16 because God told them so we could say
definitively that is false because it is
not logical the resurrection though does
not contradict God's nature and it is
not illogical therefore we have no
rational or scientific reason to
disbelieve it but of course that's not
enough to say that there's that that
there isn't necessarily reason to
disbelieve it that's not enough that's
not the same thing as saying that there
is there are positive reasons to believe
it but I do think there are positive
reasons to believe it and and I'll give
you two first history okay what's so
incredible about Christianity is that it
makes historical claims even I would say
you know in the grand scheme of things
you might you might even say recent
historical claims recent in comparison
to the whole history of the world it
says that a historical event occurred
2,000 years ago and it's very specific
about what that historical event
entailed now if it made that historical
claim and provided no evidence to
support it then I think we'd have every
reason to dismiss it
if a religion is going to claim that God
himself entered into human history at a
particular point did a bunch of stuff
and then died and was raised and
appeared to people after his
resurrection we should be able to
provide documentation to prove it I mean
you can't very well go and say that and
expect someone to believe it and just
take you at your word because there's
this is this is supposed to be a
historical event something that actually
physically happened and that people
witnessed and documented so then we can
say well where is the proof and we have
indeed I think quite a bit of historical
proof what is the historical proof well
we have the epistles of Paul first of
all and I say the epistles first of all
because they were even though the
Gospels come before the epistles in in
the Bible chronologically the epistles
were written first they're written
before the Gospels and though Paul was
not one of the original twelve apostles
he does testify to what the what the
twelve reported and he also gives us you
know Paul I think gives us maybe the
best evidence in the entire New
Testament if you look specifically at
first Corinthians 15 and this letter was
written probably in AD fifty-four
fifty-five so only twenty years or so
after Christ and this letter is also
among the seven letter the seven of the
epistles of Paul that nobody no scholar
disputes was authentically written by
him and that's important because there
are secular and atheist scholars who
attempt to argue that certain of Paul's
epistles were not written by him the
pastoral epistles especially first and
second Timothy and and Titus they'll say
many secular atheist scholars will say
those well those probably weren't Witten
by Paul because it's a different style
of writing and he appears to have you
know changed his perspective on certain
things now I think that's a that's a bad
argument those those letters were
clearly written by Paul as well so the
secular scholars are wrong on that point
but the point is that first Corinthian
with first Corinthians you have a text
that even the most skeptical will admit
was written by Paul himself which I
think is is pretty compelling and what
does it say well you go to chapter 15 it
says for what I received I passed on to
you as a first important that importance
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures that he was buried
that he was raised on the third day
according to the scriptures and that he
appeared to Cephas and then to the
twelve and that he appeared to more than
500 of the brothers and sisters at the
same time most of whom are still living
though some have fallen asleep then he
appeared to James than all the Apostles
and last of all he appeared to me also
as to one abnormally born so here we
have the significance of this is um you
know most scholars that have looking at
that looked at this text say that this
is not just Paul freestyling here this
is a very early Creed this is a
statement of faith that he says was
given to him and which he is passing on
which means that by the time of this
writing in fact by the time of his first
visit visit to Corinth so a few earlier
a few years earlier than that this Creed
had already taken taken shape it had
taken shape very quickly remarkably fast
actually and it tells us some basic
facts about Jesus including that he was
crucified they died he was buried he
rose from the dead and he appeared to
500 witnesses and then to the Apostles
so I think that this along with Paul's
other letters where he speaks about
Jesus's death and resurrection
frequently they all offer I think very
good evidence for the resurrection but I
think even more than that Paul himself
his story what he did his his own
biography is is even more compelling
evidence because we know that he was a
very strict Jew who originally
considered the Christians to be to be
heretics he helped to round them up and
secured them but something happened
something quite sudden occurred and then
he changed there was a change in him and
he went from a persecutor of the
followers of Christ to persecute it in
the name of Christ now how do we account
for that as a skeptic if you're a
skeptic how do you account for that
I haven't really heard an even half away
convincing argument the best you can do
to try to explain we've got this guy
persecutor of Christians strict
observant Jew who comes to believe that
Jesus rose from the dead and then goes
and travels around the region preaching
this putting his life in jeopardy
writing these letters how do you explain
that if if the resurrection never
occurred the best you can do I think
your only recourse really is is to claim
that Paul was just a madman that he was
a lunatic that he had a hallucination on
the road to Damascus and and then he
went insane and he decided to travel all
around the region preaching gibberish
now the problem with that is that we
have the epistles we have what he
preached we know what he preached we can
see it for ourselves we're not getting
at secondhand we're getting it from him
and it's not gibberish it's not the
ravings of a madman it's very dense very
beautiful theology and philosophy this
is obviously a deep thinker this is this
is a very intelligent lucid human being
you can tell that if you simply read his
letters so that that explanation doesn't
work you know you've uh you've probably
heard the the the trilemma argument the
three L's popular popularized by CS
lewis liar lunatic or lord and the way
that that argument goes what CS lewis
said is well when it comes to Jesus
although a lot of modern people will
like to say that well you know he was
just a great moral he wasn't the Son of
God he was just a great
morale teacher who said a bunch of great
stuff and then he died and that was it
but CS Lewis's point famously is that
well you you you can't really do that
you have to either accept him as the
Lord or condemn him as a liar or a
lunatic because a great moral teacher
who is merely mortal wouldn't go around
claiming that he was the son of God so
either he was the son of God or he was
an evil person or he was crazy now I
used to like that argument use to think
it was a very good argument and with all
due respect to CS Lewis who is one of my
favorite humans to ever walk the earth
I think that actually I've come to
realize that that argument is not very
good in fact it's not a great argument
because it's kind of a straw man in that
it leaves out the l word that almost
every skeptic will actually choose which
is legend so actually it's liar lunatic
lord or legend most skeptics most most
atheist most non-christians even those
who are theists but are non-christians
most of them what they'll say is yeah
well well Jesus was you know he wasn't
liar who knew tick or Lord he was a
legend either he didn't exist at all or
he did exist but he never said the
things that were attributed to him
they'll try to say you know for instance
well most of his claims of divinity
happened in the Gospel of John which is
the last one written so John made that
up and blah blah blah you know these are
the arguments they try to make obviously
I think that argument is absurd but if
you aren't going to accept Christ as
Lord then legend is really the only
option you have to go with and so that
is the option that most atheists and so
forth will go with which is why the
trilemma thing just kind of breaks down
but I think a version of this trilemma
argument works much better for Paul than
it does for Jesus because with Paul you
have to believe that either he was
telling the truth about
Jesus or he was a pathological liar or
he was a lunatic there really isn't a
fourth option there is no tenable 4th
option for Paul because we have his
writings Jesus as far as we know never
wrote anything at least we have no we
have no we have no writings of Jesus
aside from what he wrote in the sand
when the adulterous woman was going to
be stoned to death but with Paul you
know we do have his writings and so even
the most radical skeptics you know they
can't deny his existence and they can't
claim that he didn't say the things that
we claimed he said because we have his
own words so then what's it gonna be we
know Paul's not a legend so read through
the epistles what's it gonna be
is this a lunatic speaking when you read
the epistles do you think this is a
crazy man no I think clearly not is it a
liar well he certainly appears to be a
man of great integrity and sound ethics
what's more he's given his life over to
preaching this news around the world
he's risking his life in the process why
would he do that for a lie so that seems
to leave only the first option that he's
telling the truth
he's telling the truth not only about
what was reported to him but also about
his own conversion experience and his
own encounter with the risen Lord so I
think that's you know Paul Paul gives us
great evidence what other evidence do we
have well obviously we have the Gospels
we have four canonical Gospels we don't
know exactly for sure when they were
written we don't know for sure which
order they were written in a theist will
try to say that we don't even know who
wrote them that they were anonymous
writings but I think that's completely
ridiculous it's ridiculous because we do
know who wrote them their names are on
the documents and you and and and their
names have always been on the documents
you go back and look at the ancient
manuscripts and their names have always
been attached to them so these are not
anonymous writings and you know these
days in terms of when they were written
these days marking priority is popular
that is that many scholars especially
secular ones say that mark was written
first and then Matthew and Luke and then
John last of all there does seem to be
unanimous consensus across the centuries
starting very early on that John went
last and that he wrote his gospel when
he was an old man
so everyone seems to agree on that but
for a long time it was thought that
Matthew wrote his gospel first the
Church Fathers thought that you know and
it doesn't really matter that much
although you can see why secular
scholars want mark to have gone first so
they are going to try to work the
evidence in such a way so that mark can
go first and why do they want mark to go
first of all because mark was not an
eyewitness neither was Luke so it's
convenient for mark to go first in the
mind of a skeptic because the Synoptics
Matthew Mark and Luke are called
Synoptics because they're so very
similar and it's clear that somebody
went first and then the others used that
first one as a source though not their
only source so if Matthew used mark as a
source although Matthew was an
eyewitness and Mark wasn't then the
Atheist thinks he can argue well Matthew
must not have been eyewitness because
what kind of eyewitness would use a non
eyewitness as a source well this isn't
really a problem at all first of all
there's a very good chance that Matthew
did go first you know that he was the
first gospel the earliest traditions say
so which is pretty strong reason to
believe it these are the people that
were you know around within a century or
so of the gospel being written they all
believe that Matthew went first but but
anyway mark was a companion of Peter
Peter was in a privileged position as an
apostle and we know that he saw things
and he was likely told things that the
others weren't he was he was he was
closer to Jesus than Matthew was so if
Mark did go first and he got his
information from Peter that make sense
that Matthew though he was a disciple of
Jesus as well would refer back to Peter
through mark in any case whatever the
order we have within a few decades of
Christ death death four Gospels that
attest to Christ's life and work and
death and resurrection
these Gospels are written clearly they
are written in biographical fashion
according to how biographies were
written back in those days they weren't
written like modern biographies but they
are written like ancient biographies and
they also lack the kind of dramatic
detail and embellishment that you would
expect if these were made-up stories
in fact in fact we do also have very
ancient made-up stories about Jesus so
we know what those look like if you go
to the apocryphal Gospels the so-called
Gospels of Peter Judas Thomas Mary which
which are made up [ __ ] fabricated
forgeries and these do contain wild and
obviously fabricated stories I think the
Gospel of Thomas has a story about for
instance about the Child Jesus murdering
another child in the village when he was
a boy I'm not sure why you would want to
have Jesus doing that but that's that's
that's in the I believe it's the Gospel
of Thomas has that but the church
uniformly rejected the apocryphal
Gospels and that's important the church
did not just accept any Jesus material
could get its hands on it's not like it
it had no discerning process it
subjected these writings to rigorous
analysis and would only accept the ones
that were authentic even if the
authentic ones were frankly a bit more
boring than the fake ones
so the Gospels are are very compelling
evidence and we should also note here
that although we don't have the
originals of any of these documents we
do have a ton of early manuscripts
thousands of them and what's really
incredible I think is that these early
manuscripts written over the course of
many years by many scribes match up
extremely extraordinarily well now
you'll sometimes hear from atheists you
know you'll you'll hear sometimes hear
them say that um well there are hundreds
of thousands of variants in the biblical
manuscripts differences in other words
between the manuscripts and then they'll
say that well it was like it's like the
game of telephone
you know this story of Jesus started in
the you know around the
thirty ad and then it was passed down
it's like the game of telephone and it
was morphed and changed and so on and so
forth but that's actually not what you
see when you look at the manuscripts
that the vast majority of the
differences in the manuscripts are
irrelevant - they're just typos
basically they're you know ancient typos
when it comes to the substance when it
comes to the significant information
they're they they're identical there is
no evidence at all that anything was
added or taken out that would change the
fundamental meaning of the Gospels so
that's very significant now some people
demand that we you know have evidence
outside the Bible and I think that's
kind of silly personally the best
eyewitness accounts of Jesus were
included in the Bible because they were
the best accounts so what you're saying
is oh I want another eyewitness account
well if there were other eyewitness
accounts of that same veracity they
would have been in the Bible the ones
that are that are really good are in the
Bible for a reason so to ask for other
accounts I think is kind of disingenuous
or in other words what I'm saying is to
discount all of the eyewitness accounts
that are in the Bible because there in
the Bible is extremely disingenuous but
um we do have other accounts as it
happens we do have other mentions of
Jesus there are some Roman historians
who lived in the apostille ik age who
provide independent non biblical
non-christian even anti-christian
attestation of Christ's life and death
Josephus is one I'm sure you've heard of
Josephus Jewish Roman historian and now
he you know he he his reference to Jesus
is disputed it's clear that there was
some embellishment later on some
Christians added to it but it's also
clear that he did at least mention Jesus
and then even more interesting Tacitus
another historian
around the same time as Josephus first
century and this is a guy who didn't
like Christians he had this is what he
says in one of his writings he says
Christ the founder of the name had
undergone the death penalty in the reign
of Tiberius
by sentence of Pontius Pilate and a
pernicious superstition was checked for
the moment only to break out once more
not merely in Judea the home of the
disease but in the capital itself were
all things horrible and shameful in the
world collect and find a vogue so this
is extremely significant because they
detest not just to Christ's existence
but to his death under Pontius Pilate
and to the belief the superstition he
calls it that Jesus rose from the dead
and this is obviously someone who hates
Christians and is very insulting towards
them so he has no reason to make this up
at all but even he attests to this so
you'll notice you don't have there are
plenty early critics of Christianity
none of them claimed that Jesus didn't
exist that the Christians you know are
making all this up
he's a mythical figure the early critics
of Christianity who would have been in a
position to know if this stuff was
completely made-up they don't claim that
so a ton of evidence very good evidence
and then the final category of evidence
we have is the church itself how it was
formed under what circumstances you know
we know that something happened
something happened to cause the early
Christians starting with the Apostles to
believe that Jesus was the son of God
and then to give their whole lives over
to this belief and even to give their
lives up to this belief you know
tradition tells us that that the
Apostles were all martyred I believe
that to be the case we don't have
documented proof for all of them but we
do for some it's generally accepted by
pretty much everyone that Peter was
martyred we have very early writings
that attest to the fact that Peter and
Paul were martyred well something
happened that made Peter decide that he
was willing to die for this man Jesus
who he knew and if the resurrection of
Jesus was alive then Peter would have
known it he would have participated in
the lie and would be dying for something
that he knew to be a lie and that's very
difficult to believe and we know that
Christianity spread somehow against all
odds this obscure cult of
News running around claiming that a
criminal who had been crucified actually
come back from the dead and was the Son
of God this strange collection of
illiterate peasants somehow they managed
to start a movement that eventually and
rather quickly took over the entire
world you know see skeptics will want to
compare Christianity to n22 other
religions and they'll make this kind of
plurality of religion argument well
where they say well there are so many
religions out there and they're all
basically the same I mean how can you
claim that one is true and the others
aren't
well except the Christianity is not like
the others that's just that's that's
that's a frank ly stupid thing to say
even if you don't believe in
Christianity you have to admit that it's
different it is unique you can't deny
that you can only try and explain away
the uniqueness but you can't deny its
uniqueness no other religion in history
has done what Christianity did
especially in that context under those
conditions and so quickly that in and of
itself doesn't prove that Christianity
is true but it does mean that you can't
go around saying well it's just like
every other religion you do have to
admit that it's unique and once you've
admitted that and then you will you
allow then you allow for all the other
evidence and you look at all the other
other evidence I think it starts to pile
up and it becomes rather overwhelming so
these are all really good reasons to
believe in Christianity rational reasons
historical reasons scientifically
plausible reasons are they sufficient
though is this all you need well there
is a strand of Christian apologetics
that that would say yes this is enough
this is all you need you can prove
Christianity historically you can prove
that it's true and then you can accept
it entirely based on the evidence so if
you go you know you look up guys like
Mike Lee Kona Gary Habermas
Lee Strobel with the case for Christ I
never saw the movie I did
the book finally recently actually and
that's the approach that they take you
know they'll say that well you you know
you believe in Christianity surely
because of the history you can prove it
historically Habermas is fond of saying
that he believes Christianity because of
the data well I do think the data is
good I think the history is good I think
the evidence is very strong I think the
evidence is enough to make you stop and
take this seriously and pay attention
but if you're really intent on
disbelieving you can always explain
everything away so the evidence is good
it would even say it's overwhelming it
is not sufficient in and of itself
you still need faith so that is the
second reason why I believe in
Christianity you have the evidence you
can't completely discard faith you can't
get around it nor should you try because
there's no shame in it it's not
irrational I'm not embarrassed to say
that I have faith in Christ's atoning
death and resurrection now the evidence
can lead me down a path towards the
truth and get me pretty darn close to it
but eventually I'm going to come to a
chasm with the truth on the other other
side and I'm going to have to make a
leap a leap of faith you know that you
are gonna have to make that leap of
faith but you have to take a leap either
way so either you make the leap toward
Christ or you make it away from him
either way you're making a leap I make
that leap towards him God gave us a
historical event that we could learn
about explore come to understand study
and he also gives us faith through the
Holy Spirit which speaks to us in our
hearts and convicts us but the point is
and it's important it is faith
yet it is a rational faith it's a
reasonable faith as William Lane Craig
would say it's a faith that does not ask
you to take leave of your senses
or deny your reason or put your
rationality on hold or to never you know
to never think logically about things it
is a faith that is grounded
in an actual physical historical event
it's a faith that says yes this thing
happened go go learn about it for
yourself go look at the evidence you
know where this is not some like secret
cult where we're not going to reveal the
truth to you until you've been fully
indoctrinated you know that's not what
this is this is here's the evidence go
look for it yourself
so to be a Christian it may mean
appearing like a fool to the world but
it doesn't mean actually being a fool we
can keep our wits we can be intelligent
realistic rational people and yet still
have faith because ours is a God of
light of truth who says Here I am here's
the truth now enter into it and learn
and that I think is a really amazing
thing have a great weekend everybody
Godspeed